- As I mentioned that your new
album is called, Love Sucks,
which, well, sometimes it does.
- [Avril] Mhm. Let's face it
- [Kelly] But I heard, ironically enough
that you met your new
boyfriend while making it.
- [Avril] How funny is that?
(Kelly laughing)
- I went into the studio,
I'm literally like, "Okay,
here's where I'm at."
Like, I'm over love. I need a hot minute.
Like, I'm like, I'm jaded
on love right now, like
- [Kelly] Flick. Yeah, so.
- [Avril] And like, so you
kind of have to like do
that when you're in your writing sessions,
Just talk about like
where you're at and stuff.
So I wrote that song, Love Sucks,
set that, set the tone for this album.
Yeah, and then a couple like
days later I had a boyfriend.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Avril] That didn't
last long did it, Avril?
(crowd clapping)
- [Avril] I'm literally never single.
- [Kelly] I know, but I love
that it's like, you're not
wanting it. It wasn't even
like you're searching for it.
- [Avril] It was like the
first time in my life.
like I had just like moved.
And I moved out to Malibu,
and I like was like starting my life over.
And I was like, all right, like, I'm good.
Like, I'm just gonna focus
on myself and like do me
and just like, give it a break.
Plus, I haven't had like the best luck,
but I mean I've had amazing relationships,
and they've been like
long term, and stuff.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But like, I was just kinda,
like, I been focused on myself and it just
like really didn't last
- [Kelly] [Laughs] It happens.
And you were like or I'll go on this date.
Oh, that was awesome.
Yeah.
- [Avril] But made an album
called Love Sucks but it's also
like super lighthearted
and like funny and fun.
And it's like, kind of just
like the ups and downs in my
life and love and just
like, it's a good time
- [Kelly] which is relatable.
- [Avril] Yeah. For a lot of
people and like my first album
it's like, yeah. am I kind of
still writing the same ****
but like you know, it's
like I was writing when
I got out of high school
like fresh outta high school.
Like just like having
crushes for the first time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And now on my seventh album
it's like my, uh, you know I've had
I've had experiences
I've lived, I've learned
and, and no change
- [Kelly] Well that's I think
it was a good thing though.
- (Avril Laughing)
- [Kelly] But, no, no, no And
apparently they stay the same